we suspected this was coming the
palpable conflict between what Donald
Trump has been saying and what doctor
foul Chi the top infectious disease
doctor in the country has been saying
the conflicts have been obvious for
months and yet they danced around the
differences until now everything that
has happened to dr. Anthony Fauci has
been absolutely embarrassing for what it
says about our country coronavirus
protesters chanting fire foul Chi at
their protests conspiracy theories about
doctor foul Chi including bogus videos
about coronavirus that target him as a
bad actor Senator Rand Paul attacking
him earlier this week scolding him
saying you're not the be-all end-all and
now Donald Trump seemingly seeing the
door open to start more directly going
after doctor foul Qi has publicly broken
with foul Chi and saying that doctor
foul Chi's claims earlier this week
during the Senate hearing about we know
we may not be able to open schools in
the fall Trump is now calling that
unacceptable unacceptable and what Trump
means really is that it's politically
unacceptable and I'll explain why in a
moment let's take a look at what Donald
Trump said actually because you know
it's just to me it's not an acceptable
answer especially when it comes to
schools the only thing that would be
accepted was I said his professors
teachers etc over a certain age I think
they ought to take it easy for another
few weeks five weeks four weeks who
knows whatever it may be but I think
they have to be careful because this is
a disease that attacks age and it
attacks health and if you have a heart
problem if you have diabetes if you're a
certain age it's certainly much more
dangerous but with the young children
and students it's really just take a
look at the statistics it's pretty
amazing
notice that Trump doesn't present any
counterfactual Trump just says foul
cheese answer is unacceptable and that
doesn't mean it is scientifically
unacceptable it doesn't mean that it is
medically unacceptable what Trump means
is it's politically unacceptable because
if there's no school in September it's
probably not good for Trump's reelection
in November if there's no school in
September that signals likely economic
calamity continuing to such a degree
that it's going to hurt Donald Trump in
November Trump also throws in there by
the way you know kids are mostly fine
and not affected by the virus we've
already covered that children number one
can spread the virus hugely even if they
don't get significantly sick they can
bring it to all of their homes from
school then their parents get it then
their parents can't go to work then
their parents can't earn money you you
understand the problem of this and we
are also by the way seeing a kawasaki
like disease in kids with corona virus
that still needs more investigation
there's been several dozen cases so far
we really don't know that much about it
so far
now what this conflict means in terms of
doctor foul G's future I don't know one
thing that I like in terms of breaking
from Trump is Mitt Romney we've been
watching Mitt Romney and Mitt Romney has
started regularly ribbing Trump during
the Senate hearing earlier this week
Romney actually asked doctor foul Chi
Donald Trump has been saying Obama is to
blame for the fact that we don't have a
corona virus vaccine right now
that's ridiculous of course and he
offered doctor foul me the opportunity
to answer and of course doctor foul she
confirmed no not having a vaccine right
now has nothing to do with Obama it also
has nothing to do with Trump and I want
to talk about that in a moment on a
separate topic I my impression is that
which regards to vaccines the the were
I'm critical of what we've done on
testing on vaccines we've done a pretty
darn good job moving ahead pretty
aggressively and yet the president said
the other day that President Obama is
responsible for our lack of a vaccine he
add dr. Fauci is President Obama or or
by extension President Trump if they do
thing that that made the likelihood of
creating a vaccine less likely are
either President Trump or President
Obama responsible for the fact that we
don't have a vaccine now or in delaying
it in some in some way
no no Senate not not at all certainly
President Obama nor President Trump are
responsible for not having a vaccine we
moved as you said because I described it
in my opening statement rather rapidly
no one is ever gone so listen I like
what Mitt Romney is doing I'm not
rehabilitation Mitt Romney's image I'm
not doing any of that stuff but
seriously who can deny that we would be
better off right now in this crisis with
Mitt Romney as president rather than
Donald Trump but to the other point that
I want to make when we talk about we
don't have a vaccine right now and
that's not Obama's fault obviously and
it's also not Trump's fault I want to
make really clear that you need to be
prepared for a new line of
disinformation that's going to start
relatively soon Donald Trump is going to
take credit for vaccine when there is
one Donald Trump is going to take credit
for treatments as we find more effective
treatments and it has nothing to do with
him understand that it has absolutely
nothing to do with him we eventually are
going to find a vaccine and eventually
people are going to get vaccinated and
eventually the pandemic will end in the
same way that on yesterday's show
outlined for you how no matter what the
death toll is Trump will say thanks to
me it wasn't 2.2 million whether it was
going to be 60,000 or a hundred thousand
or a hundred and sixty thousand or
whatever the number is Trump will always
take credit for it when in fact Trump's
responsibility is that it's going to be
worse than it had to be because of his
slow action when it comes to
vaccinations and treatments they have
nothing to do with Trump but he will
eventually take credit for those as well
depending on when we get those things he
will use them to justify his reelection
in November and he has nothing to do
with why we don't have a vaccine right
now and he will have nothing to do with
us eventually having a back vaccine
never mind that the vaccine that ends up
being widespread in use in the United
States may actually be developed by a
different country altogether don't
forget that stuff this is
part of the disinformation propaganda
that they are using which is deflect on
any of the blame
oh listen PPE the problem was Obama and
governor's but we solved it by after two
and a half months finding PPE for people
ventilators oh yeah the problem was New
York didn't buy a whole bunch of them
two years ago and this and that the fact
that we were slow with the national
stockpile that doesn't figure in
anywhere and much the same way Trump
will get credit for the death toll not
being as high as it hypothetically could
have been Trump will try to take credit
rather and it's up to us to remember the
death toll is higher than it needed to
be look at South Korea got their first
case within hours of the United States
getting its first case
don't let them Gaslight you remember I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman and I love
hearing from you let me know what you
think